you want to know what makes whiskey the
most epic drink of all time
how about ping everything drinking a
glass of whiskey a day helps prevent
cancer you know it also prevents you
looking like a tool whiskey is the only
drink that can blind you and cure that
blindness at the same time people who
drink whiskey are less likely to get
Alzheimer's and more likely to get laid
statistically so you want to keep that
sexy body drink whiskey low carb and fat
free oh you're a gluten-free vegan well
I've got this great new diet plan it's
called shut up and drink your whiskey
yes whiskey has gluten in it just like
your vagina has sand whiskey is the most
important meal of the day that's what my
kids taught me whiskey is the only drink
that when you drink it and wince you
actually look cool see whisky is aged in
oak casks what's Jen aged in grandma's
perfume balms knowing a lot about wine
means you're a [ __ ] knowing a lot about
vodka means you're a club douche knowing
a lot about whiskey means you're a true
American Hero God invented whiskey so
the Irish wouldn't rule the world that's
a fact
did you know that George Washington had
a whiskey distillery yeah it's as
American as apple pie whiskey
owns you and not the other way around
that's because whiskey is nobody's big
whiskey puts hair on your chest even if
you don't want it the best cure for a
whiskey hangover more whiskey
you know who'd be impressed you drink
whiskey Ric Flair Tom Selleck John Wayne
President Eisenhower Rachel Maddow rowdy
roddy piper
eddie van halen my boyfriend's
motorcycle mechanic SEAL Team six
Bukowski
oh yeah and me listen the truth is that
the only thing you really need to know
about whiskey is that you should be
drinking it right now Cheers
anything hot girl drinking whiskey is a
hot guy drinking whiskey I tried to wink
and it looked bad